our 8 news now investigator is the first  to tell you a teenage McDonald's  employee is accused of shooting into a  crowd on Fremont Street sixteen-year-old  naquinton Norsworthy facing several  charges after two people were hurt  police reporting that shooting happened  at the Fremont Street Experience back in  the 29th of December documents say Norse  worthy just got off his shift and got  into a fight with customers now we  received a statement from McDonald's a  short while ago it reads in part this  kind of behavior goes against the values  we have as a company and is not  tolerated we took immediate action and  can confirm this individual is no longer  employed in our restaurant